hello everyone this is Emir from audio
science review I thought I started a new
series covering some of the text reviews
that I post on on the website if you go
to audio science review.com and click on
this reviews tab you see a list of every
video that I've done and if you keep
scrolling down you know more and more
will show up
um instead of doing a video on each one
which can be very time consuming and I'm
probably too lazy to do that for you
you're welcome to go read the text
reviews I thought I'd do a sort of a
Roundup of the reviews of the week
um on this thing and try this as an idea
and see if it works well
so if I go back a week or so
um uh one of the by the way in here you
also see third party reviews by other
members this one for example but it's by
somebody else so I'm only going to cover
the video the reviews that I've done
um so let's go back a week or so it
takes us back to this product uh it's a
cheap little
um uh phono preamp from a company that's
kind of famous for these budget products
art audio and the member gave me the
money hundred dollars for me to go buy
and test this product so I went ahead
and purchased it it's a hundred dollars
on Amazon and
um it's actually a cool little box you
know 100 you're not going to get fancy
enclosures and what have you but it's
got fair amount of controls and the
buttons actually feel pretty good
um but what's unusual about this device
is that it's not just an analog preamp
for phonos uh as it's commonly done but
actually it has a digitizer that lets
you capture that audio and digital
domain to USB so you can basically rip
your LPS uh as some people call that and
you can see that excuse me on the back
where we have a USB connection it also
supports uh speedif and what have you
um and uh you can actually select to use
this device either as a phono preamp
meaning it has a lot of gain to uh just
having low gain and be a line uh an
audio interface you know if you were to
buy a professional uh audio capture
device so you get both functionality in
one
that lets me test each part of this
device separately so I can test this
capability to just be a digitizer
compared to compared to all the other
adcs that are out there and then test it
in combination with a phono preo so
starting with that
um the way that works is that I play for
my audio Precision analyzer I generated
one kilohertz tone
I have to set it to some voltage for
unbalanced audio RCA I set it at two
volts and then captured the output
digitally and then the audio Precision
analyzer uh is able to analyze that
digital bit stream just like you can do
that it can do so on analog bitstream so
we see our one kilohertz tone that we
put in but unfortunately we also see all
these Distortion products are created by
the analog the digital converter that's
inside this box
I've set the gain in here enough so that
I get to zero dbfs which is a maximum
digital value you can get but without
going over because if you just go over a
hair and digital domain these Distortion
products shoot through the roof and
that's the problem with digital it's
great until you get saturate it and once
you saturate it you can help breaks
loose so I've set this at two volts and
measure that and if you combine all the
Distortion products and noise and
compare it to their how strong are the
input signal was which is this one
kilohertz tone it's about 80 decibels
below that so the energy of all this
stuff is 80 DB below that so what does
that mean well we can plug it into a a
simple ranking of of all the adcs that
I've tested both consumer and
professional know and unfortunately this
lands in the red category meaning that
you know you could do a lot better
ideally we like to see everything in
green and then you know it's wonderful
when we get something in Blue uh but now
this is a 100 device so we can't be too
critical for the classic device it is
you know it's not bad it could be better
but it's hard to complain
um is noise performance is just a little
bit better signal noise ratio it's about
87 DB whereas you know distortions about
80 DB so uh you know it's not bad and
certainly a lot less noisy than the LPS
that you're gonna capture the groove
noise alone is it's in a 30 DB range so
you have plenty of of quietness in there
uh um you know in the capture device
um at two volts is a little bit unhappy
um if I sweep from five millivolts to
two volts we can see around this point
all of a sudden it starts to generate
distortions so the cleanest signal is
around -4.2 DB
voltage and I think I have that
somewhere else coming up later on what
that is uh or do I have it here no I do
not but anyways about one point some
volts or so that's the limit if you want
to use it as a capture device
but you know the main purpose is uh
digitizing uh LPS so let's switch it to
that mode and what that does it
generates a lot of gain uh I think it's
about 40 DB gain or so
um there's a nice little uh I shouldn't
say nice there is an indicator in here
that that says I'm clipping uh if I
adjust the volume to here as you can see
right in that Arrow that's barely the
point where this light wants to come on
and if you did that you're actually
capturing a 10 DB below maximum volume
maximum output so that but that's
actually a good thing as you'll see in
in a second
um so with the gain set lower and uh we
measure that and because of the Ria
Equalization for LPS the uh
headphone uh sorry headphone phono
preamp needs to have a lot more gain in
base frequencies and that causes it to
for this noise to be elevated here
um so normally we get a graph like this
but ideally you wouldn't get all these
spikes in it
um I have to deal with this a lot
because phony stages are very sensitive
and they can pick up a lot of noise and
usually I find that one way or the other
to reduce these spikes down to you know
if it's good implementation I get it
down to almost invisible in this case
the device was very sensitive to noise
level uh the shape of this graph and
these spikes and this is the best I got
if you just plug it in it's horrendously
worse than this and uh you know maybe in
your situation get it to be better but
you may also forget it to be a lot worse
so it seems that the uh the phono stage
is picking up noise uh from what's
adjacent to it inside this little box
our sign ad which was addb for just at
low gain and now with phonos with a
phono mode turned on with both
Equalization and High Gain and we lose
quite a bit of it we're down to 59 DB
uh what is 59 DB means if we run the
exact same test with the same five
millivolts of input simulating what a
moving magnet cartridge would produce uh
the ranking is the fourth worst one that
I've ever measured so definitely not a
good showing you know an average device
would be in the 70s and state-of-the-art
or best ones of tests that's around you
know mid 80s so we're leaving a lot of
performance on the table and
unfortunately it's in the noise
department where you you can't hear it
you know Distortion here is that minus
80db your cartridge and LP system is
going to have a lot more Distortion than
that but here you know you could be
hearing noise from the from this product
um on this thing now one of the most
important things in in a fullness stage
is how good it applies the reverse
utilization if you're not familiar with
that to best optimize this Limited
Format that's called LP we pre-equalize
the response at recording onto the lp
and then we do the inverse in the hopes
that we get a flat response so the job
of the phono stage is to back out that
Equalization with inverse
filtering and ideally you get a flat
line in here from 20 to 20 kilohertz and
a few uh funnel stages are almost there
this one's not quite there you get some
variation in there but it's really
Smalls about a half a DB or so error
here on a positive side and 0.2 DBS on
the negative side so for a phono State
especially a budget one is quite good uh
you know you'll have bit of exaggeration
of high frequencies as what this has on
this thing it has a nice subsonic filter
which my opinion should be standard
feature every one of these phone new
stages so when you do that you know you
lose response starting at 50 hertz
whether that's a good response you know
probably now you really want it to be
flatter to a little bit lower and then
drop like a rock prior to that but it's
certainly good enough and it's really
selectable so you can decide on this
thing
um the sign ad in the dashboard is
heavily influenced by noise as I
explained but the analyzer is able to
actually exclude the noise and we can
look at the Distortion and we see that
at 10 kilohertz distortions very very
low we're at -90 DB we're talking
digital audio you know domain but it
increases to minus 60 DB because of that
Roe Equalization so that's just normal
contest we
um is to see what is the overload margin
I mentioned that I measure the uh uh the
dashboards at only five millivolts in
and as a typical average for a moving
magnet uh uh cartridge but when you when
LP is spinning if you have any noise or
pops and static from it those can
actually have quite a bit more amplitude
uh than the five millivolts so
um to uh if you if it reproduces
precisely you hear x amount of noise but
if the phono stage actually Clips when
it's trying to reproduce those pops and
ticks it will actually exaggerate them
substantially and so to get a quiet uh
playback as quiet as the lp can be
despite all those noises you want to
have a lot of Headroom in there so we
run a sweep we're actually running that
very small values here is 0.1 millivolts
over here and go all the way to as high
as we can to see when clipping happens
and the clipping is uh
depend in this case being the digital
device is kind of tricky in that
remember what I said once it reaches
zero DB all bets are off and it
saturates so you have to fiddle with
that gain stage to try to find the you
know position where it's not clipping
but at the same time it doesn't get you
know too quiet as far as what is
amplifying even with my optimizations
best case that I got on this is 79
millivolts before it it saturates and
clips and look at what happens when
eclipse the Distortion shoots up to 100
Distortion here so we're not dark and
smaller massive Distortion we're talking
just you know basically nothing but you
know crud coming out of there
um you know I'd like to see 100
millivolts over here as far as the
Headroom so five millivolt display back
we like to see it allow up to 100
millivolts before it's saturates and
here we stop at 79 millivolts is that
the world now if your LPS are clean it's
probably okay but just know that there
are better phone stages without this
problem and partially this problem is
created by the fact that we have a
digitizer in front of this and it's able
and it can clip very easily you can see
if you set it incorrectly where the gain
is set to what the device tells you
right before it goes red you only get 13
millivolts of Headroom before it
saturates and goes to 100 Distortion
again so you know you want to back it
off even more than that and if that
makes things quiet hopefully your power
amp can can compensate for
so you can read about the specs in here
so overall to me the problem in here is
this noise
susceptivity here I like it to be much
more quiet than here yes it's a budget
product but we gotta have standards in
there so I think it's unfortunate that
they didn't manage to keep the thing uh
more quiet than the than they could they
give up a lot of performance you know we
got 58 DB instead of uh you know where
we started where it's 80 DB without the
phone or stage activated so expect a few
DBS the loss but not as much as we have
in here okay so it's not one of my
favorite products some of their other
products are better so why don't we go
back and see what's next uh the next one
is wound up to be a very controversial
product
um to test there was a speaker from
Yamaha called ns10 it was a consumer
speaker
um that was sold in Japan and then
brought to America and I imagine other
countries and it basically lived his
lifetime and he was basically a failure
and that Yamaha was going to discontinue
uh that speaker but somebody grabbed it
and The Story Goes to somebody in Tokyo
saw one and grabbed it and started doing
a mix on it in creating you know music
um thought that this speaker did a
better job of telling him what was wrong
in their mix
than their proper professional speakers
well that idea caught on fire you know
somebody else grabbed it the next thing
you know
thousands of these speakers with this
iconic white cone are being bought and
placed on top of the meter bridge on on
the console and this thing became the
most ubiquitous speaker there is for for
production we're talking I think 90s and
2000 or 80s I forget that the dates that
it was very popular
and eventually the speaker was
discontinued and I think it's been 20
years or so since it was produced
there's been a lot of requests to
measure the speaker
um so I went on eBay trying to find an
ns10m and everyone that I could emboss
the studio version which was basically
the same thing
um and all I could find was crusty
samples with literally mildew and
watermarks and you know red yellowish
cones and speaker beat up cabinets and
they wanted hundreds of dollars for
these things
and then I remember reading that people
said there's a new version of this thing
has been implemented by a company called
avanton Audio Allentown Pro
and they uh uh they call it CLA tan
named after mastering engineer uh that
helped them with the design and they
claimed to have found the Wolford is
almost the same or the same and the same
Twitter and they built the Box exactly
the same put it all in there and people
say Hey you know you could test this one
as a proxy for the original and the good
news about testing this is that it has
an aged whereas if I test a 20 year old
Yamaha understand who knows if the
drivers have degraded and whether that's
representative of what was there before
so I believe that and on and this
product seems to be getting a lot of
positive marks on on different YouTube
videos and reviews that are read where
people say yeah it's a little different
than ns10 but otherwise you know does
the same thing so I said great wanna
test this nobody wanted to send it
700 on Amazon to uh buy this thing and
it arrived
now it turns out right on the year that
this product the original Yamaha was uh
discontinued
um the study came out by uh fairly
experienced uh Consultants Newell uh
Philip Newell uh somewhat well known in
acoustic circles and certainly in the
Pro industry and they actually had a
contract for a high five magazine or Pro
magazine I don't know which to go and
measure a bunch of professional monitors
and they also measure the Yamaha and his
10 amp and if in an anech chamber so if
we start with that we can see the
frequency response they measured on the
ns10 am uh it's not anything we'd want
to see in the speaker so it's a sealed
enclosure so that's a sort of a constant
slope going up this is the base response
but as soon as you get to 200 Hertz
response starts to climb go up up up up
up and then it drops like a rock and
then you have these resonances which are
basically a woofer Breaking Up Normally
you want to really filter out the woofer
response let the trip the Twitter take
over and produce a mix that too so that
the two get a constant uh amplitude so
we get a flat response but here that was
not attempted so you know we get
completely uneven response so up here
we're at 95 DB down here we're at about
86 87 DB so an 8 DB rise a sort of a
gradual rise and then dropped like rock
and then resonance says uh so you know
if I were this you know test that
speaker today and saw a response like
this it'd be just horrible I mean you
never want to use a speaker like this
for production so
uh question is how does that compare to
the oven tone cla-10 because is is it a
proxy of it or not is it did they do a
good job cloning it turns out they did
not do a good job of cloning it so let's
look at the response there on my system
now keep in mind that my measurements
are higher resolution than what you see
in and even in that antichoic chamber so
it's more authoritative than that but we
sort of see a similar Trend with the
same closed box response over here and
same gradual rise although it doesn't
look anywhere sort of like a flat slope
that they had uh we see they sort of
gradual in here shelving thing then it
sort of goes up and it comes up there
but instead of dropping back down like
this one did we don't drop back down we
actually go down here there's a peaking
resonance here the narrow frequency and
then the response actually stays quite
hot till you get about six or seven
kilohertz and then I say six or seven
kilohertz it sort of shelves down but
then it has another resonant peak in
here that eventually dies off
another horrible
performance in here
um you know it sort of starts off good
but look at this mess in here so
obviously anything you play through it
is going to exaggerate uh sort of lower
treble and all the way up to most of
travel range and then it kind of drops
off and so you basically don't have much
bass and all you're going to hear is
upper mid-range and and trouble with
some nasty resonances over here the
second thing we do this advance that
wasn't done then is that we look at what
is the directivity of the speaker which
means how similar are the on-axis versus
off axis response as we predict in that
if you just take a woofer on Twitter and
just slap them in the front of the box
and don't attempt to shape the uh the
waveform that coming out of that Twitter
that Twitter widens this response as
soon as it takes over from the woofer
and therefore the sound that you hear
off axis uh will not be even I've done
very videos on that and maybe I'll link
in the description for you to go watch
on on do activity errors and we have a
classic major directory view error which
means that up to about two kilohertz the
on-axis and off axis are similar but
once you go past two two kilohertz all
sudden there's strong variation between
off axis and on axis what does that mean
that means if you take this identical
speaker and put it two different rooms
it's likely going to sound different
because those Reflections whether
they're absorbed or not whether they're
close to you versus not it's going to
change the tonality of the speaker
so despite what people thought at the
time that oh you know speakers great you
can you know the sound of it you go from
room to room no you don't necessarily
know the sound of it because there's
room dependency in here due to
directivity error you know at the time
people didn't think that stuff was as
important even though the knowledge was
there but they didn't know that so at
any rate they uh we have that classic
directivity error as well so quick thing
is no this speaker is not a replacement
for ns10m and it's more broken than what
I call a broken so I understand M was
broken and this was a more broken
version of that uh on this thing so if
we look at what's broken in it and we
can see the woofer in here uh if I just
measure it by sticking a microphone
close to it we can see the woofer
response comes in here and gets kind of
jagg it and screw you over here but as
that's the response goes out then all of
a sudden we see these resonance Peak
over here because the the crossover
filter isn't steep enough to kill them
and then at the same time we see that
trouble it all has also non-flat
response in it I'm sorry the Twitter has
non-flat response and you combine this
with this you're just going to get a
mess you know crossover frequency is two
kilohertz and it's just not how you
design speakers today clearly the
designer had had the wrong concept there
um uh there are some good news in in
there because the speaker is not being
pushed to produce much bass is actually
pretty low Distortion when it comes to
base but if you do push it it's still a
small speaker so at uh 960b SPL it does
get distorted in base which we're not
very sensitive to But be sure to Sega
sensitive to the mid-range distortions
and and treble Distortion and and we got
plenty of that over here and uh
anyway I showed this Distortion both as
a relative and an absolute relative one
is the one that you want to look at most
of the time unless we have a reason to
look down here
um typically we have two models for
predicting higher speaker performs when
we measure the non-equate response
versus where if you put it in in your
room and one of the things we do is that
we look at what are the typical what's
the typical strength of the reflections
coming out of the speaker the we have
the on-axis sound but also what sound
hits the walls and comes back at us and
combines and we take all the early
Reflections and we sum them together and
get one line which is this green line
and we like to see this line be very
similar to the on-axis response because
then it'll mean that off and on access
sounds similar and
usually the trend is that they're
similar but there's less energy off
access because you go sideways through
speaker you hear less height the speaker
is the opposite in that off axis that
sound is actually brighter than the
on-axis signs this arrow that I've drawn
usually points down is actually pointing
up and the day rate is this uh kind of
screwed up now note that in in the near
field use this model doesn't work as
well although I should say all the
well-designed uh near flow monitors do
superbly in this department as well so
it's a good proxy to not cleaned off
access responses even though in absolute
this model doesn't hold uh on this thing
so where's the problem we actually see
that the problems is uh when you have
the speaker in in the in the vertical uh
axis is where it's got most errors uh on
this thing so horizontally is actually
not as bad uh one of the worst things is
actually the reflections behind you you
want to try to absorb that by the way
the speaker can be mounted vertically or
horizontally and so depending on which
way you mount it you switch this for
that and vice versa I tested it
vertically even though you usually see a
meter Bridge horizontally is actually
vertically screener sounding the
measuring than it is horizontally so if
you do have it I highly suggest that you
have it on you know vertically then then
horizontally
um the reason for that is you can see
how good the horizontal Reflections are
when you when you have it vertically
hope you can keep up with me speakers
Place vertically and here we're showing
the horizontal reflection so what his
side was in the studio and comes out
your ears is actually pretty good
vertically is bad but we're less
sensitive to that if you turn it on the
side as most people do then this becomes
your horizontal one and all these bad
Reflections are not what's Audible and
his Society was coming at your ears so
do not use this and if ns10 was anything
similar to a do not use it horizontally
like everybody seem to be having on top
of the meter Bridge they should have
used it vertically to get a more correct
response just like early Reflections
this Arrow should be pointing down it's
just pointing up when it's pointing
horizontal or up by definition it's
going to sound very bright and we don't
like that and that's what you're going
to get
um I won't go into this stuff you can
see it you can see the director via
errors over here and so forth
the paper talks about one of the reasons
this is a good speaker is that it didn't
you know it didn't have resonances that
lasted for a while and therefore was a
fast sounding speaker that whole concept
of faster slows actually complete myth
is dozen view size they'll just there's
no such thing as as fast or slow you
have resonances which means that the you
know things linger and time domain but
if you have resonances and frequency
domain you get those Peaks that I showed
you and indeed if I run my waterfall
graph in here you can see all these
elongated things and if you walk them
back you can see Peaks everywhere
there's one of these things there's also
a peak there and so you don't even need
this waterfall if a display is not if a
frequency response not flies it's got
these peaks in it then you have
resonances unfortunately when Niel and
and crew
measured that they said this very long
time frame of 100 milliseconds in there
whereas I only have four or five
milliseconds in mind and so all these
residences probably died off before it
got here or possible that the original
Yamaha is much cleaner than this oven
tone I can't tell you until I test one
of those but to me I don't think this
data is authoritative and I think it
probably had resonances if you had high
resolution measurements and tested it
um uh one thing that you know I usually
don't comment on step function because
it's just a useless measurement in
general but here we can use it to see if
this speaker has similarity to that
design we actually see that it does so
our step function is matching that of
the uh uh antichoic measurements of
ns10m if that's the case that means this
could also be representative and a
stand-am in which case it means that it
wasn't a fast speaker anyway it was just
a myth thinking that it was fast speaker
there's such strong resonances you can
actually see kinks in the impedance
graph at higher frequencies that often
don't show up so here's the uh uh you
know response on that as far as
listening tests uh I listened to it and
the first track I played on it I thought
I'd wired something wrong I I was just
not hearing all of the music I was like
it was like a three-way speaker that
Dimitri wasn't plugged in or something
and then I switched to another track was
like oh no it is sounding kind of okay
now so it's really that when you screw
up the tonality of speakers so much it's
emphasizing the emphasizes so much that
it feels like some parts of the music
are taken out and other parts are pushed
forward
and I I have not heard a speaker sound
this bad and not only there is a
tonality wrong but there's a ton of
distortion in high frequencies it's just
all those uh the jagged response and
resonances just create odd grungy sound
uh on this thing so bottom line is do
not buy the speaker I don't know what
you why you would want to buy the
speaker people talk about using these
speakers so the mix translates better I
don't know Han on earth a uh using a
broken resp speaker with its own
resonances they're adding colorations to
the mix and exaggerating response in a
way that even crappiest headphones or
speakers these days don't do would tell
you something about your mix whatever
you change in your mix because you hear
it on this speaker but don't hear it on
another one you shouldn't be making
those Corrections because we don't want
to use speakers like this we don't use
speakers like this even the most budget
speakers today crappy ones have better
response than this flatter
responsiveness so to the extent this
speaker finds flaws for you you think
that's in your mix if those flaws are
not audible on a proper studio monitor
don't go chasing those and go fixing
things that don't exist because when you
do that you're now compromising
performance on a problem monitoring the
speaker and we as audio files want to
you know will deploy systems that are
neutral we do not deploy speakers with
responses that uh you know look like
this
so for you to do any kind of mix
optimization based on this you're making
a mistake you know if you're hearing
this resonance in here and you pull down
that part of the mix but we don't have
that resonance we don't have this large
hump so to me this entire concept of
mixed translation this helps with that
whether it's this one original and it's
uh it makes no sense to understand sorry
it makes no mistake to me so this is a
discussion we're actually in this thread
we have the people from Pro industry
defending this kind of practice you know
to death and I'm coming out and with the
with arguments that I've been just
making that this is just the wrong thing
in video production we have standards
basically we Define what's neutral and
both the production and reproduction
match the same standards so if you do
that color red will look like proper
color red that was seen when the video
content was produced same things done in
photography to some extent although you
know people don't look at photos anymore
and in in same light but still use a
calibrated monitor to do your photo
editing
but audio doesn't have anything like
that it's just what I call Wild West
people come up with these weird ideas of
how you use a speaker like this to
better optimize the sound for every
playback device it makes no sense to me
the only thing you would be optimizing
is for another playback device that
looks like this and in the old days yes
we have clock radios and crappy stock
radios in our cars or people listen to a
lot of music and
so yeah maybe it could produce this kind
of mix it would be good today we've gone
way past that we have digital delivery
of music that's extremely high fidelity
uh even earpods are very good and none
of them look anything like this with you
know with discount response so anyway
long documents going on in the thread if
you want to join the pro or or I guess
what I've been talking about uh you're
welcome to go do that as you can see
it's gone on for 26 pages but the votes
are pretty consistent 133 people 91
think that this is a terrible speaker
and I usually have a policy of not
returning products after I review them
and I get stuck with tons of equipment
that I'm the last owner of it but this
one really bother me that it's been sold
as a clone of ns10m and it has nothing
to do with little to do with ns10 app so
it should be its own model its own thing
and the company should not Market it
this way and as a minimum should have
done a measurement like I did to verify
it looks like ns10 amp they could have
easily modified the Twitter response to
make it look like an S10 but they didn't
they could have gotten a good sample of
understand and done that test
anyway so that's that uh review maybe I
should have done independent reviews I
don't know let's continue on maybe watch
this whole thing for two hours but he
had plenty of time we're 32 minutes into
it so the next one was uh an odd bird I
don't test many CD players there's not
that much interest in CD players but
occasionally somebody in one of the
members has a CD player and I figure
it's good to test things once in a while
categories we don't bother with
um this is a uh hopefully I'm
pronouncing it right KN uh Chinese
company actually fairly uh well-known
Chinese company of Dax and audio
products and they've made a CD player
um for 279 dollars and I thought it
looked pretty good for 279 dollars all
metal box kind of nice large display in
here slot loading
um transport uh you know you want to
have a drawer that opens uh but uh you
know it's a lot loading it works
um I thought you know if I just post the
reviews of measurements of this device
how do you know what that means so I
wonder my Dusty cabinet and and uh took
out this Lin CD player about uh 1999 or
year 2000 uh it's their mimic model if
you don't know Lynn it was a company it
was very famous for their turntables but
when digital came they got into digital
so they're still around
and at the time cost sixteen hundred
dollars which was a lot of money uh if
you convert it to today's currency is
three thousand dollars today so to pay
three thousand dollars for the CD player
which then you could buy a 100 one and
today you can buy a hundred dollar one
it was a lot of money does it do better
than this one we'll find out it's
digital digital so bits are to say
um I made a mistake in first uh I lost
my old test CD and I went and made a new
one and made it on Windows and used the
Windows Media Player to make it and I
did not realize the Windows Media Player
actually applies loudness compression
loudness matching for all the tracks
that you give it by default so it took
all my precisely created test samples
and butchered them to some extent so
that made some of the measurements
faulty luckily a member on the Forum uh
saw the same thing have been gone
through the same process of creating CD
and he found out the auto leveling in
wmp and kind of embarrass him because
the Windows Media Player team was one of
the teams I managed years ago 15 years
ago so all embarrassing but anyway the
measurements now are correct and they
use the right test uh test signals that
I burned on them so we go ahead and feed
the CD player one killer Stone and what
we see is these you know pretty elevated
distortions in here
um and the cyanide is just 83 DB
remember I just tested an audio
interface for 99. sign that that was
close to this so this is not a good sign
out
um dynamic range of CDs about 1960b if
you don't get there if you did there is
93 DB so we're 10 DB hard Distortion
than the theoretical noise floor of the
CD you know so basically they have a one
dollar DAC in here and and not a lot of
effort was put in there to make it you
know High Fidelity so if you're buying
this the transport for analog output of
it
not a good idea so now how does it look
if we take my expensive today's three
thousand dollar Lynn high-end CD player
how did it do it did 5 DB better 88 DB
but the Distortion is still way higher
than it should be uh so even then you
know you paid all that money in your 2
000 20 years after the CD format was
introduced and you still didn't get you
know what what the bits were telling you
to produce every time you fed at one
kilohertz you got a cluster of
distortion that came with it uh so
pretty disappointing this number should
have been in you know 90s and uh not Ada
but certainly better than this one uh at
83 DB uh for the k
um so now let's switch to digital output
uh you would think a digital output
spitif would be then identical to the
what the bitstream that's on a CD saw a
bit exact so digital now there's no DAC
involved so before we go there let's
look at how the Lin player
um uh handled that and we see our one
killer Stone and we see this constant
noise floor and no Distortion you know
it's digital is digital and there's no
room for Distortion and as I mentioned I
did that 16-bit format button and CD has
the best case dynamic range of 93 DB and
which then turns out to be the sign out
because we have no Distortion so this
basically measuring this noise floor
which is determined mathematically to be
about 93 DB so and the output 0 dbfs
which is what we told that and the
frequency is basically one kilohertz so
everything's perfect with the Lin good
implementation as it should be but it's
not perfect on this kncd player it
actually is producing Distortion
products like how could that be I mean
how do you get Distortion when you
haven't converted the bits to anything
else well the bits have been somehow
modified you know if you look at these
things they're running at odd harmonics
in here uh actually it's about rmx to go
one two killers and it skips and goes to
five killers and so forth so there's a
pattern to this and what I think is
happening is that one of bits are either
toggling incorrectly or stuck zero is
stuck one so it actually has a base a
problem in the bitstream that's coming
off the CD is getting corrupted and
going out
a simple test would have caught this but
it was not and so we're getting
Distortion even coming out of spitif on
this thing and so not good at all
digital is not digital bits are not bits
and we actually even getting slight
level difference because of that so not
good uh you know if you thought you just
get this hook it up to a deck and life
would be good it's not uh on this thing
so
the kind though it's a little bit more
quiet uh so about 92 DB versus you know
90 DB of Berlin
um
we can look at their filter
implementations they're the typical what
I call Lazy default filters in the DAC
in that instead of sharply jumping down
at 22 kilohertz they uh you know sort of
slowed down but that's same as the Dax
by default that's what they produce as
well and we see that the Lin actually
has got a problem in that it's not
attenuating out of band response an
ideal DAC would go here and would go
down to Infinity zero instead of that we
see that it's got a high noise floor in
here and the can actually has much lower
noise floor
so you know I sort of mixed a message
you know which one of these CD players
is better uh on this thing we can make
measure Jitter the bits are coming out
of spitif yes it's digital the data is
consistent but the bits can actually
toggle back and forth and that's all
going back and forth when fed to a DAC
if you can't filter that it actually
results in uh analog Distortion
um so if we feed these two signals it's
a little hard to interpret this but
these spikes are supposed to be there's
part of this special signal that's in
there so pay attention to this noise
floor we see that the uh the Lin has a
sort of a consistent noise floor in here
it's kind of flat but it sort of slopes
up whereas the Cayenne
um it goes in here and it actually Rises
up here and then it goes back down to a
lower level this says that this clock
has some Jitter
but slow free consider it's not you know
rapidly changing it's just slowly
changing so it's sort of a mixed message
which one's better on this thing
so
um I can actually look at the Spectrum
of of that Jitter and analyze it and say
hey what causes this variation let's
just look at the Jitter not the data but
the Jitter and we see that the can
actually has slightly lower
um Jitter and we see that both of them
have Jitter but the client has uh you
know a little bit less of it except for
this one Spike over here at 16.5
kilohertz there's something digital
that's running in there possibly the
microprocessor is like controlling the
front panel display
excuse me and he's generating noise and
that noise is actually causing the spit
of clock to dance back and forth
proportional to uh this signal so it's
actually causing Jitter on that
transport
and that's not a good thing uh to have
so how do we know that's not a good
thing let's take the spit of output of
both of these CD players and run them
into a high performance stack in this
case topping D7 yes that's sitting on my
desk and when we feed it to that again
this pulse train is supposed to be there
but notice this this set of oops sorry
you're not seeing what I'm saying here
notice this set of spikes here and this
set of spikes in here so the topping was
not able to filter that out and that
cayenne's interference pattern from up
here it actually goes through the deck
and comes out the other end of a high
performance stack so you couldn't get
rid of it now the levels are at minus
120 DB so about 5 DV lower than
threshold of hearing so it's not an
audible thing but just know that bits
are not necessarily bits We have
basically you know if you screw up the
expeditive clock you know you will pay
penalty in measure performance uh on
this thing
okay so but let's go back to and you
know just using top uh sorry topping
d70s I'm just looking at it what it
would look like if you drive it by Lin
you get this idealized output of 93 DB
everything looks cool the noise floor is
very clean all looks well as good as
16-bit format can produce when Lin is
the transport but if you use the car and
as the uh transport what happens look at
these same distortions we were seeing on
a speed if this time those are data
errors remember I said they can actually
butchers the bits the digital samples
bits are not bits so if you change the
bits the topping deck Faithfully
reproduces them and instead of just
having one kilos tone we have you know
this whole sequence and now these things
are rising up to minus 100 DB they're
not at a minus 120 DB which clock Jitter
was so
news this is about just simply a broken
implementation has a bug in it and this
is why you measure by the way it's not
always for performance also for
functionality uh just measure this with
even rudimentary devices you could
capture the bitstream over spitif into a
computer and compare the bits it would
likely fail that kind of task so not a
good thing sorry to say hopefully
company will go back and find this bug
and fix it uh on this thing
so we got that
um let's see we can motor through these
other ones I don't know how but we'll
try
there's a company back in the 80s that
or 70s or 80s maybe it was 80s that got
uh quite a name for it called Tice
and he got the name based on something
else that was in crazier than that some
people bought this uh digital clock from
then Radio Shack stores and brought it
home and they thought when they had this
digital clock and it's an alarm clock
one o'clock was running they said their
audio system sounded better
don't ask me why that could happen but
folks believe that not only did they
believe in that this company ties took I
think the same clock and modded it and
sold it under their own names and called
the TPT and then folks said that it
sounded even better or different than
the Radio Shack uh alarm clock and I
think this one was like two or three
hundred dollars for alarm clock was only
30 bucks and uh the thing was called the
Tice clock this was a digital clock and
created an incredible abroad between the
Believers and non-believers and unlike
today there were a lot more
non-believers than than there are today
people thought it would just sign of
craziness that somebody would say you go
buy this thing and and it improves the
sound of your system by just having a
clock plugged into the wall in your room
uh the company went bankrupt or broke I
don't know what happened to them they
disappeared for years and years but then
somebody sent me some of their products
Unfortunately they didn't have the clock
but they had two other products one of
them is called the Tice audio enhancer
uh what's it called uh yeah TPT enhanced
line conditioner there's almost no
information out on these things
um so I took it apart it's a wooden box
and it's just something you plug into
the wall there's you don't plug anything
into it and whatever magic it does it
does when you plug it into your outlet
so theoretically it's cleaning up your
power going into everything else your
whole house
so I uh it has no screws but the glue
they had used was kind of flimsy and so
I just pried it up with a screwdriver
and pulled the panel off and what do you
know what's inside this this sort of uh
uh water kettle cabling they use goes in
here and just loops and loops and loops
and then it sort of stops in this group
the group is somewhat kind of good
they're used to uh basically hide the
electronics if you want to pot it as we
call it you don't want anybody to be
able to get into it you pour the stuff
in there and it solidifies and hardens
and that's that so this thing is like a
pound of this goop in here and that's it
there's a there's no Active Components
in here I don't think there's anything
connected between the two ends literally
the loop of wire just ending in here
and uh but hey maybe there's some magic
is performing in there that we don't
know so let's measure it as always I
measure things by first measuring my AC
line so I have a special probe that
divides the voltage by a hundred so
that's not lethal anymore but also it's
differential meaning that the probe is
very good at not picking up noise from
the air and imposing and so what we're
seeing truly is what's coming out of my
AC outlet and here the AC outlet the AC
waveform you can see the tops of it are
flattens because that's where we pull a
lot of energy out of our AC line so we
deform it and this is our main frequency
and when we deform it we generate all
this harmonic Distortion and all this
noise so clearly it's a very very
distorted signal it's got a 2.2 percent
or 2.3 percent uh uh no you know noise
to uh signal ratios 60 hertz and 122.3
volts so what happens if we plug in this
TPT device ties TPT at the same time
that I'm making this measurement answer
is that not a thing changes so you know
then condition anything all the noise is
the same all the distortions the same
we're the same 2.3 percent and nothing's
changed you know this little bit of
change in voltage is just run to run
variation ac lines not 100 fix
so a little hard to Overlay these two in
your mind but so let's just look at it
for your transform where we put them on
top of each other and not only that we
go crazy go to
um 1 000 Killers so way way way way past
our hearing which stops around here and
when we measure the AC Spectrum in blue
we see that it has all this noise and
it's got some interesting uh sorry again
you can't say it we've got all these
spikes in here and uh so definitely not
a clean thing but when we plug in the
Thai CPT
nothing changes even though there's you
know high frequency noise which would be
trivial to uh shunt with a capacitor or
something and you just get rid of these
not even that's been done so that wire
goes nowhere literally just goes in that
group when like group is an insulator
and there's really nothing there to to
change the signal
but you know how it is people say well
your ears can hear things that the
measurements can't hear well I I was
listening to music the whole time with
my uh you know four thousand dollar Dan
Clark stealth uh headphones the
reference quality headphones extremely
low Distortion and of course there's
sealed headphones to the block outside
notes I'm just hearing music you can't
see my rme audio interface but that's
what's the driving the headphone and uh
then the computer is plugged into the
same outlet that all all of this was
plugged into and I'll tell you I plugged
the thing in quickly slowly leaving them
taking it out else later there's zero
audible difference whatsoever in my
testing so it shouldn't make a
difference measurements show that it
doesn't make a difference and clearly I
didn't hear any difference
now the member didn't just send me this
and send me this other Oddball device uh
apparently they made this power cable
this times the power cable and one end
of it you know is mail the other side is
the IEC cable that you plug in but
interestingly enough it has a two
switches it's got a and b written on it
so what the hell is that about
um so I uh had a couple of security
screws and uh took a bit of effort to
try to open it I opened it up and all I
see is the cheap little switches in here
and on one side nothing's hooked up so
basically either connects these two
wires together or it doesn't
at first I thought this was the you know
in in electrical circus we have a green
is the safety ground uh black in in U.S
at least it means hot and white means
neutral and basically AC signals between
the white and and black and I look at
this thing and I'm like wait a second if
you throw the switch to the right you're
basically disconnecting the neutral if
you did that the you know the device
would shut down yet when I measure the
two end to end with my meter the
continuity was there meaning that it
wasn't disconnecting anything it wasn't
until I peek underneath this one and I
saw that the white neutral cable you can
actually see there it actually also goes
end-to-end in other words between the
two ends of the cable we have the same
standard three wires going from one end
to the other
in addition to those three wires it has
two more wires one white one and one
black one and each one of them Shadows
the corresponding wire in there so we
the this black wire in here this is a
thinner black wire that goes to the same
places this black wire goes and same
with the white wire so and the white and
the black on the two ends they actually
have two wires going through a beefy 14
gauge wire whatever this is and not so
beef it is little wire
electrically that's the only thing
that's going to do when you connect that
is that it lowers the resistance of the
thick Wire by hair because a thick wire
already a pretty low resistance you know
having another I don't know 18 gauge
wire next to it it just changes
resistance and that may maybe change the
power capabilities of that cable from
delivering I don't know two kilowatts to
1.95 kilowatts or something like that so
it's not going to make a difference
anyway but surprisingly they say that if
you engage one switch your base changes
and if you switch the other one your
treble changes pretty amazing that just
putting another wire in parallel with
another wire would would know to change
the treble and bass and make things
tube-like so
Let's test the idea though I took a top
in d70s again that's always on my desk
so I measure it by itself we see it is
incredibly good sign out of 120 DB
Distortion is down money started at 30
DB so totally transparent and so let's
disconnect the standard cable that went
into this and plug in our new magic dice
Cable in there and we see nothing
changed active performance went down
here because you know temperature
changes and you know and turn the thing
on and off a measurement changed a
little bit so ignore that it got a
little worse let's give them the benefit
of the out that nothing got worse I
played with the switches while watching
this display another thing was changing
the switches made no difference
whatsoever
now if if base in trouble are going to
change we better see that in frequency
response obviously we don't see it in
frequency response frequency response
identical with or without the switches
with or without this cable so this one
absolutely positively does nothing it's
a really simple-minded idea of of
building a tweak you know compared to
today they talk about cryogenically
treating this and nanoparticles that and
this material for the insulator and I
don't know uh you know a whole bunch of
fancy claims this will be just as simple
ideas hook an extra set of wires in
there and put switches on them let
people play with them uh know that
people thought it made an audible
difference because you toggle someone
your brain changes uh on this thing so
uh you know I'm not going to make a
recommendation or not but hopefully you
understand there are a lot of crazy
ideas out there and some of these ideas
go way back uh and while something like
this was easy to laugh at then and a lot
of people would stand next to you today
a lot of people think these things are
real and they work and you have a lot
less people standing with you hopefully
people can see that there was no magic
in in these products even then and not a
good idea to uh go chase those
okay we're going on almost one hour I
believe we have 55 minutes I better stop
here put in comments what you think of
these long formats maybe you can speed
them up as you watch them or jump around
and uh let me know if you want to see
more of these okay see you in a future
video bye-bye